كما ذكرت انا في اللقاء اللي في التشاور
اللي صار قبل قليل فيما يتعلق في القضيه
الفلسطينيه نحن دائما نلتزم في قراره
الشرعيه الدوليه حتى نحرج فيها الكيان
الصهيوني وبالتالي موقفنا من الكان
الصهيوني موقف واضح ومق بكل اسف هذا
البيان لم
يعرض الخلين العام يقول عرض لم يعرض هو
ارسل بالواتساب في البارح بالليل لم يعرض
على على اللجان مره واحده ولم يصلني على
مر سمعتني فلذلك
موقفنا من القضيه الفلسطينيه ومن حق الشعب
الفلسطيني في
مقاومته وفي ايضا استعاده ارض المغتصبه
ومحاربتها للكيان الصهيوني ستبقى قائمه
بغض النظر عن ما ورد يعني ما يمكن ان يفسر
ما ورد في البيان وبالتالي انا اعتقد كما
ذكرنا في السابق في اجتماعنا السابق اللي
كان صباح اليوم
اعتقد مهمتنا في المرحله القادمه حتى يمكن
ان نوحد المواقف وحتى يمكن ان نجعل من
القضايا العربيه قضايا بالفعل نستطيع ان
ان نكون مثرين فيها هو ان يستمر التشاور
وان تستمر اللقاءات وان يستمر ايضا
الالتزام في كل ما يصدر عن الشرعيه
الدوليه لان هذه هي سلاحنا اللي نحارب
فيه
m